[MUSIC PLAYING]
FERNANDO GARCIA: You
do want to be inspired
from the very beginning.
Creative collaboration was
happening since the day we met.
LAURA KIM: The way Fernando
starts his process by sketching
and the way I start my process
by draping or cutting fabric,
but we're ultimately ending
up at the same place.
I would definitely
recommend latching
onto people that are
strong enough to push you,
but also vulnerable enough
to listen to your ideas.
What I learned about how
to be a leader from Oscar
was he was always having fun.
We were always laughing.
I think that's very important
in a creative environment.
This class is not just
for fashion students,
but also for people who
want to start a business
with a partner in any industry.
In this class, we're
going to teach you
how Laura and I work together.
LAURA KIM: We're
going to do fittings.
FERNANDO GARCIA: How
we design a collection.
LAURA KIM: How you sketch.
FERNANDO GARCIA:
How we build a team.
LAURA KIM: How I drape.
FERNANDO GARCIA: I think
no matter what, you just
need to be comfortable
to be around somebody
who can challenge you.
I think those
honest conversations
makes us good partners.
FERNANDO GARCIA:
When we both started,
we didn't understand what it
was like to launch a brand.
And we realized that designing
was perhaps 50% of the time.
I get inspired a lot by
just random people walking by.
Could be like a picture
of a really cute dog.
Or a hot guy on
a beach that I saw.
If you were to start
your own business,
you should really understand
who you are as a person
and find someone who can
do stuff that you can't do.
FERNANDO GARCIA: That
might be the next runway.
I'm Laura Kim.
I'm Fernando Garcia.
And this is MasterClass.